[Musica]
nell'immaginario collettivo internet è
concepito come un'entità esterna
distante lontana dalla realtà delle cose
e in realtà è semplicemente lo specchio
del mondo è la sua proiezione digitale
così come il mondo
anche internet è un luogo complesso e lo
è soprattutto per i più giovani che
avendo un identità meno consolidata sono
un pochino più suscettibili ad alcune
dinamiche del web
pensiamo a al cyberbullismo cioè al
bullismo in rete
secondo l'osservatorio in difesa che ha
realizzato la più grande indagine in
italia su bullismo e cyberbullismo il 61
per cento dei ragazzi sotto i 21 anni ha
subito letteralmente almeno una volta
nella vita un caso di bullismo parliamo
di praticamente due ragazzi su tre e
vedete qualora non sapessimo
tecnicamente cos'è il cyberbullismo il
ministero dell'istruzione ci ha fornito
una come dire una definizione che dal
mio punto di vista è molto calzante il
cyber bullismo è letteralmente l'insieme
di azioni aggressive
realizzate mediante strumenti
elettronici che hanno un grande
obiettivo che è quello di provocare un
danno a un coetaneo incapace di
difendersi è una definizione che sposo
per due motivi uno perché c'è una
componente di attacco di aggressione nei
confronti delle persone e secondo perché
punta anche il dito contro l'incapacità
di difendersi di molti ragazzi vedete il
paradosso è che ad oggi il modo in cui
stiamo concependo di risolvere questo
problema è illudendoci che un giorno
potremo improvvisamente estirpare il
cyberbullismo e che quindi in qualche
modo il web diventi un posto magico e
incantato e perfetto che è un paradosso
perché non mi pare che siamo riusciti a
fare la stessa identica cosa con il
mondo offline
non mi pare che siamo riusciti estirpare
il bullismo dalla realtà delle cose
la mia idea la mia umile idea è che
oltre a provare a rendere il web un
posto più sicuro dovremo soprattutto
provare a rendere i ragazzi un pochino
più forti perché è molto più facile
lavorare sul carattere della singola
persona che non provare a cambiare il
mondo tutti insieme tutto in una volta
mi chiamo federico sbandi ho 31 anni
lavoro da otto anni nel digitale come
consulente per le aziende e da quattro
anni
gestisco una scuola di marketing
digitale che è rivolta ai più giovani
quindi vivo internet seppur con quanto
più distacco possibile come uno
strumento di lavoro in cui le aziende
fanno delle cose per comunicare a
vendere e i ragazzi provano magari a
costruirci una carriera ebbene
risulterebbe impressionante scoprire
conto anche dei professionisti del
digitale a tutte le età ea tutti i
livelli di importanza in realtà non
comprendano ancora oggi alcuni concetti
basici come ad esempio la differenza tra
il cyber bullismo è semplicemente una
discussione critica in rete e attenzione
che questo è un grande problema perché
se tu ritieni che qualunque attacco che
ricevi fondamentalmente sia passibile di
un blocco di un banda di una limitazione
nell'interazione con un essere umano non
stai comprendendo qual è il confine
appunto tra l'attacco l'insulto
l'aggressione è semplicemente una
discussione critica c'è un istituto
americano che sia ma con paris tech che
nel 2020 ha fatto un'indagine sul
rapporto tra genitori e digitale è
letteralmente quello che è venuto fuori
è che il 43 per cento dei genitori i cui
figli hanno subito in qualche modo con
un atto di cyberbullismo
sapete come hanno reagito sapete come
sono intervenuti i genitori prendendo il
cellulare dei figli entrando nei loro
canali social e bloccando tutti quelli
che in qualche modo erano risultati una
fonte negativa di interazione nei
confronti dei loro figli che è una
reazione estrema ma a volte accettabile
ma non sempre perché nel mondo offline
nella realtà fisica delle cose quella
che tutti viviamo non funziona così
punto primo se non capisci il distinguo
il confine tra un attacco online è una
semplice discussione critica tenderei a
bloccare tutto quello che non ti piace
anche se in realtà potresti andare
avanti nell'argomentazione ma
soprattutto nel mondo offline noi non
possiamo bloccare le persone se c'è
qualcosa di negativo con cui io devo
interloquire interagire affron come dire
mi devo confrontare con la negatività e
non posso bloccare le persone ed è per
questo 20 ore ai ragazzi insegniamo
soprattutto nel mondo offline ad
argomentare le loro tesi e in generale
anche a rispondere eventuali insulti
verbali provando a difendersi provando a
difendersi perché a un certo punto ti
devi difendere
in questo caso potremmo arrivare al
punto in cui diciamo bene bene allora se
il ragazzo non può autoeducarsi perché
evidentemente non nasce imparato sul
digitale tutti lo abbiamo l'illusione
che siccome sono giovani sanno usare
internet non mi pare che anche i miei
coetanei abbiano del tutto capito come
funziona la televisione anche se ci
siamo nati e cresciuti la stessa
identica cosa farebbe il web ma allora
chi se ne deve occupare
chi è che in qualche modo deve educare
queste persone potremmo pensare alla
scuola la scuola perché la scuola ci
occupa dell'educazione
eppure sin dalle elementari le medie a
volte anche il liceo il digitale è come
se non fosse neanche pianificato nei
programmi formativi di questi ragazzi
perché diamo per scontato che tanto non
li riguarda poi però la prima cosa che
gli mettiamo in mano a un cellulare e mi
risulta che così come per prendere la
patente guidare una macchina insegniamo
alle persone come funziona la macchina e
quali sono le regole della strada
allo stesso modo ci sarebbe bisogno di
qualcuno che idealmente ti insegna sa
naviga nel web ma questo non succede
nelle università pensando soprattutto
alle facoltà di comunicazione marketing
che magari mi riguardano direttamente
anche oggi il digitale viene
letteralmente messo al pari di radio
carta stampata e tv come se nel 2021
avessero la stessa importanza quindi la
scuola è rimasta indietro chi se ne può
occupare allora chi è che si occupa di
educare i ragazzi al digitale magari
genitori e la famiglia
eppure anche la famiglia sembra non in
grado di assolvere a questa funzione
pensiamo al fatto che ancora oggi molti
genitori anziché provare a costruire
quella con come dire quell'autostima
quella confidenza intorno a un ragazzo
che potrebbe rappresentare la sua
corazza nel mondo ancora oggi molti
genitori moderni tendone per proteggere
a creare quella bolla di vetro un
esempio che mi auguro possa risultar v
come dire familiare una volta gli
insegnanti avevano molta più autorità
nei confronti dei ragazzi se un
insegnante tipo univa la tua famiglia
veniva informata e quando tornai a casa
le prendevi metaforicamente è
letteralmente oggi grillo come dire un
insegnante medio che ha perso molto
potere molta presa a livello di autorità
se si permette se osa riprendere magari
un ragazzo la famiglia va a scuola e
difende ragazzo quello che succede come
effetto collaterale negativo anche se la
famiglia si illude di difendere il
ragazzo e che non gli sta dando gli
strumenti per imparare a difendersi in
autonomia le situazioni come crisi
bullismo online bullismo offline una
qualunque situazione in cui ha bisogno
di sapersi difendere
parlo per esperienza diretta
parlo per esperienza diretta nel senso
che quando ho vissuto i miei primi anni
del liceo era una scuola privata non ho
amici e veniva presa in giro per il mio
abbigliamento per il mio aspetto il naso
grande e soprattutto il fatto che non
fosse abbastanza benestante rispetto a
tutti gli altri che non potevo
permettermi loro stile di vita
e a scuola in famiglia era come se
nessuno sentiva il mio disagio
era come se nessuno era in grado di
comprendere che in quella situazione io
non amo gli strumenti per difendermi e
mi sentivo letteralmente da solo contro
tutta la scuola
una notte fondamentale per la prima e
per fortuna unica volta nella mia vita
ho pensato al suicidio è una cosa
bruttissima 3 tremenda e in
quell'istante letteralmente dopo
l'ennesima notte che ho pensato a tutte
le cose brutte che mi erano successe
durante la giornata e tutte quelle che
sarebbero successe subito dopo ho
letteralmente realizzato ok boom mi sono
alzato sono andato diretto verso la
finestra aveva impugnato la maniglia
della finestra pensato che adesso è
finita cioè adesso adesso la faccio
finita e per un attimo non ero più
disperato era improvvisamente in uno
stato di trance in cui se anche solo per
un istante il tuo cervello pensa quella
cosa vuol dire che si è totalmente
uscito dal tuo corpo e c'era una vocina
diabolica che mi diceva fallo buttati
perché almeno finisce il dolore
poi per fortuna non è successo nel senso
che ho tolto la maniglia sono andato al
bagno mi sono guardato allo specchio
cominciato ad avere una risata isterica
pensando a a quanto fosse stato anche
solo lontanamente stupido pensare a
quella cosa a quanto le persone nella
mia scuola non meritassero in alcun modo
di portarmi in quella situazione che un
giorno in qualche modo hai avuto la mia
rivincita ma non perché volessi
vendicarmi terzo di loro perché comunque
provavo empatia verso la loro demenza ma
comunque nella vita un giorno mi sarei
riuscita di fare sarei riuscito a
ricostruire mi alla mia vita
morale della favola la mia vita è
cambiata perché mi sono iscritto a uno
sport da combattimento che era la
kickboxing e improvvisamente ho trovato
un maestro che credeva in me uno sport
in cui ero bravo è una squadra che mi
sostenerla ho cominciato a combattere
seriamente a partecipare ai tornei e
fortunatamente anche a vincerli e tutta
la confidenza che mi prendevo dal ring
la riportava nella vita offline e questa
confidenza ho cominciato anche a
diffonderla alle persone che mi erano
intorno soprattutto i più giovani
colleghi studenti qualunque ragazzo che
mi sia capitato in qualche modo del
percorso professionale o accademico e mi
sono reso conto però solo crescendo cavo
letteralmente impostato la mia vita
professionale che per me contava
tantissimi ancora oggi conta tantissimo
sulla base di un presupposto che era
quello di voler dare agli altri che
magari io non ho avuto all'epoca c'è
qualcuno che ti ascolta se comprendesse
e saper se in qualche modo costruire
delimitare la tua confidenza autostima
nel mondo che è esattamente quello che
ti serve per fare bene nella vita ma io
sono solo uno e uno non basta e ogni
volta che un ragazzo si toglie la vita
per un atto di cyber bullismo o di
bullismo offline quelle la sconfitta di
una famiglia di una società e quindi se
vogliamo davvero intervenire e operare
lavorare per rendere queste persone un
po più forti mi sono permesso di
raccontare questa storia personale
cercare di raccontare anche da dove
arrivasse e soprattutto quali sono gli
strumenti pratici concreti che ci
possiamo riportare a casa per provare a
migliorare questa situazione
consapevoli che l'obiettivo non è
schioccare le dita in qualche modo
pregare che il web cambi dall'oggi al
domani ma semplicemente che le persone
siano un po più forti o un po più forte
quindi un pochino più preparate a
eventuali avversità
penso a gli strumenti che potrebbero
utilizzare i genitori
penso che lo strumento fondamentale sia
consolidare l'autostima dei figli e io
non sono nessuno per dire ai genitori in
sala che ci ascoltano come dovrebbero
educare i propri c perché ovviamente io
non ho questa credibilità quindi non
posso permettermi di arrivare fino a
quel punto però da professionista del
web che interagisse interagisce in
qualche modo con i giovani e io vedo
vedo tutti i giorni il loro livello di
mancata autostima nei confronti del fare
scelte di vita di lavoro e anche il modo
in cui interagiscono online con i loro
pari o con perfetti sconosciuti che sono
in grado con un commento vino in ivy la
giornata è follia impossibile non
dovrebbe essere così e io lo so che è un
genitore non ha il ruolo di insegnare le
tecnicalità del web ha un figlio perché
per quello ci sono altri istituti di
formazioni ci sono delle realtà più
complesse professionali un genitore però
dovrebbe un millimetro alla volta
costruirti quella corazza nonni per
proteggerti perché si mettono nella
bolla o un figlio e una figlia arriva il
momento in quella bolla si rompe e
quella persona non è preparata le schede
del mondo se io invece costruisco la tua
di corazza anche quando io non ci sono
più come genitore tu comunque va avanti
penso alla scuola
la scuola come strumento fondamentale a
il piano formativo ciò quelle come dire
quello che viene insegnato
effettivamente ai ragazzi su base
annuale con una strategia di formazione
ed è assurdo che ligi tale non sia una
priorità cosa che invece dovrebbe essere
il digitale internet dovrebbe essere la
priorità dei piani formativi non l'unica
materia ma una di quelle più importanti
perché tra l'altro il digitale dovrebbe
essere anche insegnato da persone che lo
praticano che ci lavorano dentro che in
qualche modo siano totalmente competenti
e consapevoli di quali sono le
meccaniche del web oltre ai tecnicismi e
quindi condividerli con dei ragazzi
interessati a scuola perché con internet
questi ragazzi ci interagiranno con
altre persone
ci parteciperanno alla vita politica in
qualche modo ci lavoreranno anche quindi
dare gli strumenti di base di base per
comprendere le meccaniche della rete
significa metterli nella posizione di
poter succedere come persone come
professionisti come cittadini e l'ultimo
strumento
mi permetto di rivolgermi in questo caso
i giovani pensano soprattutto a quello
che mi è successo personalmente lo
strumento fondamentale ragazzi e ragazze
è la richiesta di aiuto perché la
differenza tra il bullismo fisico e
quello psicologico e che ovviamente in
quello psicologico non ci sono segnali
quindi è molto più complesso per le
persone di vedere esattamente quello che
succede è invisibile nella tua mente
però ti sta deteriorando tutti i giorni
quello che potete fare richiedere aiuto
perché ci sono degli enti e delle
associazioni in italia nel mondo che si
occupano esattamente di questo via
supportare di aiutare le vittime del
cyberbullismo che in qualche modo
forniscono supporto legale ma
soprattutto psicologico ti permettono di
comprendere quello che sta succedendo e
perché come dovresti uscirne e vedete io
all'epoca sono stato fortunato perché
per n ragioni miracolose ho avuto il
guizzo di riprende la mia vita in mano è
ancora oggi i miei genitori non sanno
che quel momento che quella notte sia
stato lo scopriamo che con questo con
questo speech però anche all'epoca io
non ebbe il coraggio di chiedere aiuto a
qualcuno perché non sapevo neanche che
questi enti o questa associazione si
stessa e invece esistono e ti dà una
mano e ti permettono di comprendere che
il mondo è un posto complesso
internet è una fotografia del mondo e
quindi anche il web è un posto complesso
e dinanzi alla complessità non mi la
testa sotto la sabbia impari a
combattere e se dovesse chiudere con un
consiglio un ultimo consiglio finale
sarebbe di ripetere il percorso mentale
che in quel momento di follia assoluta
ho visto anch'io per me stesso quindi mi
permetto di condividerlo che fu
comprendere che stavo totalmente
perdendo il controllo il respiro il
battito cardiaco di fermarsi un attimo
pazientare razionalizzare la situazione
renderti conto che alla fine alla fin
fine ci sono infinite ragioni per
continuare a combattere
l'importante però ricordarsi che la vita
bella è che tutto quello che ti può
succedere un certo momento la pressione
il carico la solitudine è tutto
temporaneo devi solo fermarti un attimo
e ricordati che ci sono infinite ragioni
per continuare a vivere
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]